[Music]  [Applause]  the Backstreet Boys went full country  Sunday night performing alongside  Florida Georgia line at the Academy of  Country Music Awards that was a blast  that was so much fun the Backstreet Boys  are amazing the stars in the audience  clearly had a blast watching Faith Hill  and Nicole Kidman Tim McGraw Carrie  Underwood and Keith Urban and more  couldn't contain themselves dancing in  their seats  Tim and faith were total  relationshipgoals  singing their soulful duet speak to a  girl the couple had fun celebrating at  the event these pigs hanging with Nicole  and Keith do not lie it was 100 percent  the ultimate double date night you can  have my home Miranda Lambert kept it  simple with just her guitar to perform  her single Tin Man  she also scored some major awards  including album of the year she hugged  her man Anderson east before giving her  candid acceptance speech I just want to  say um thank you for letting me smile  art break and sharing it with me  you